Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
And today we're here to answer one question:
what is a convolution?
I have heard many university students crying
in despair over their perilous journeys of
understanding what convolutions are, and why
they are useful. Let me give a helping hand here!
A convolution is a mathematical technique
to mix together two signals. A lot of really
useful tasks can be accomplished through this
operation. For instance, convolutions can
be used to add reverberation to a recorded
instrument. So I play my guitar here in my
room, and it can sound like as if it were
recorded in a large concert hall. Now, dear
Fellow Scholars, put on a pair of headphones,
and let me rock out on my guitar to show it
to you!
First, you'll hear the dry guitar signal.
And this is the same signal with the added reverberation.
It sounds much more convincing, right?
In simple words, a convolution is a bit like
saying guitar plus concert hall equals a guitar
sound that was played in a concert hall. The
only difference is that we don't say guitar
"plus" concert hall, we say guitar "convolved"
with the concert hall. If we want to be a
bit more accurate, we could say the impulse
response of the hall, which records how this
place reacts to a person who starts to play
the guitar in there. People use the living
hell out of convolution reverberation plugins
in the music industry.
Convolutions can also be used to blur or sharpen
an image.
We also had many examples of convolutional
neural networks that provide efficient means
to, for instance, get machines to recognize
traffic signs.
We can also use them to add sophisticated
light transport effects, such as subsurface
scattering to images. This way, we can conjure
up digital characters with stunningly high
quality skin and other translucent materials
in our animations and computer games. We have
had a previous episode on this, and it is
available in the video description box, make
sure to have a look!
As we said before, computing a convolution
is not at all like addition. Not even close.
For instance, the convolution of two boxes
is ... a triangle. Wow, what? What kind of
witchcraft is this? It doesn't sound intuitive
at all!
The computation of the convolution means that
we start to push this box over the other one
and at every point in time, we take a look
at the intersection between the two signals.
As you can see, at first, they don't touch
at all. Then, as they start to overlap, we
have highlighted the intersected area with
green, and as they get closer to each other,
this area increases. When they are completely
overlapped, we get the maximum intersection
area, which then starts to dwindle as they
separate.
So there you have it. It is the miracle of
mathematics that by computing things like
this, we can rock out in a virtual chuch or
a stadium which sounds very close to the real deal.
And before we go, a quick shoutout to immersive
math, a really intuitive resource for learning
linear algebra. If you are into math, you
simply have to check this one out, it's really cool.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!